Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Phineas Gage, the case that changed psychology forever. What happened when a man
had a freak accident sending a railroad spike through his brain and lived to tell the tale? The story of this man, Phineas Gage, isn't just shocking. It changed the way we understand the human brain forever. Stick around and we'll go through all the gory facts together. Hi I'm Dr. Marianne a qualified clinical psychologist and today we are diving into one of the most fascinating and influential case studies in the history of psychology and neuroscience that is the case of Phineas Gage. Phineas' story isn't just a tale of survival. It's a case that forever altered our understanding of the brain, personality and human behaviour. In this episode, we'll explore what happened to him, how it impacted his life and what his experience taught us about the brain's
incredible complexity. Let's take a look. It was September the 13th, 1848, in the small town of Cavendish, Vermont. Phineas Gage was a 25-year-old railroad foreman, known for being hardworking, responsible, and a natural leader. His job involved clearing rocks to make way for railway lines, and on this fateful day, he was using a tamping iron to pack explosive powder into a hole. But something went wrong. Somehow the powder ignited prematurely sending the iron rod which was over three feet long and an inch thick hurtling through his left cheek behind his eye and out the top of his skull. Miraculously it's said that Phineas Gage didn't even lose consciousness during this accident. He was reportedly able to walk and talk even shortly
after the accident but already perhaps a sign that he was not quite himself and was a little confused was becoming apparent because to the doctor who treated him, he is reported to have said, here is business, enough for you. Yeah, like I said, doesn't make a lot of sense. Whilst of course his survival was extraordinary in itself, really it's what happened after the accident that's captured the attention of scientists and doctors for generations since. Life after the accident. So before the accident, Phineas was described as kind, level-headed and dependable. But after the injury, his personality seemed to have undergone a radical transformation. His friends and his colleagues observed that he had become impulsive, irritable and even prone to fits of anger. He seemed to struggle to maintain his
relationships and holding down steady employment became tricky for him. One of his doctors, John Harlow, wrote that Gage was no longer Gage. The once reliable foreman had somehow become entirely different. This shows us just how profoundly the brain itself influences personality and behavior. Perhaps one of the most heartening things about this case is that it didn't end in tragedy because it also shows us about the brain's ability to heal, adapt and to find new ways to tackle problems. And even found work as a stagecoach driver in South America. Whilst there it's even said that he managed to gain some semblance of normality. His former mannerisms and social skills were more evident. This stage of his life suggests that even
in the 19th century, there were glimpses of what we know as neuroplasticity. That is the brain's incredible ability to adapt and recover. What we learned from this case. Phineas Gage's case was groundbreaking for understanding the brain's role in shaping personality and behavior. What we learned from this case. Phineas Gage's case was groundbreaking for understanding the brain's role in shaping personality and behaviour. Here are some of our key lessons. Number 1. The role of the frontal lobe. Phineas Gage's injury specifically damaged his frontal lobe, which is an area of the brain responsible for decision making, emotional regulation and social behaviour. His case provided some of the first evidence that different parts of the brain serve different functions.
2. Brain and personality connection Phineas' story challenged the belief that personality was fixed and unchanging. It showed us how brain injuries can alter someone's behaviour and character. A revelation that had profound implications for the fields of psychology and neurology. 3. The beginnings of neuroplasticity. Though the term itself didn't come about until much later, Phineas Gage's eventual ability to regain some of his former skills hinted at the brain's remarkable capacity to adapt and to heal relevance today phineas gage's incredible story continues to resonate not just as a historical
curiosity but also as a foundation for modern neuroscience and psychology brain injuries today his case helps us understand the challenges faced by individuals with traumatic brain injuries, also known as TBI. It's paved the way for research into rehabilitation and recovery, which provides hope for people themselves who experience brain injuries, but also their friends and family around them, as there can be such a significant impact when it feels like you have lost the person that you love. Ethical considerations. Phineas Gage's story also helps us to raise questions and to look more closely at how we deal with people who form case studies.
In the 19th century, it's of course fair to say that documentation and ethical considerations were far away from today's standards. Reflecting on him and how his story has been told across the years reminds us of the importance of treating everybody we encounter with dignity and respect and of course of the importance of informed consent. That is the ability to say no and to understand how you will be used and what will be said about you and in what way. Of course, it also would give you an indication of what the negative consequences for taking part might be. Then again, of course,
there are the additional ethical considerations, whether somebody with a traumatic brain injury, especially immediately after their accident, whether they really have what we call capacity to consent. Do they really understand? Can they hold that in mind long enough to be able to make those decisions? Identity and biology. Finally, Phineas Gage's case sparks philosophical questions. How much of who we are is shaped by our biology? And what happens when that biology changes. Conclusion. So what can we learn from Phineas Gage? His story is testament to the resilience of the human brain and the profound impact of biology on behavior. It's a story that reminds us both of the fragility and of course the adaptability of the human brain and mind. I want to leave you with this question. How do you think brain injuries shape identity? Do you think we are defined by our biology or is there something
more to who we are and what makes us, us? Let me know your thoughts in the comments. Do come and connect with me on socials and discuss it there. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If you found this video interesting don't forget to like, subscribe and share it with others who might also like to explore these incredible insights into psychology and neuroscience. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership which you can join from just £ pounds a month and there's also the clinical psychologist collective book the grief collective book the aspiring psychologist collective book an autistic anthology and talking heads too if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide.
With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything
will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.